moi je suis venu chercher les poules de
Houdan pour pouvoir faire la poule au
pot
alors on essaye de bien garder les
critères de beauté donc il faut bien là
houpette après faut pas trop de noir pas
trop de blanc
c'est bien de voir justement que il y a
des personnes comme toi qui travaillent
sur sur la continuité du d'une poule
comme la poule dedans qui est
aujourd'hui est difficile à élever
[Musique]
on va réaliser la recette de la de la
poule au pot donc la poule au pot tout
simplement c'est une volaille qui va
être pochée et qui va être farci avec
une farce là aujourd'hui à base de veau
et des petits légumes de saisonnalités
pour la farce j'ai du veau haché du
persil des œufs bio des échalotes les
abats de la poule de Boudon de la crème
liquide et après tout ce qui va être
garniture aromatique les oignons les
clous de girofle et les légumes qui
seront à consommer avec la poule au pot
carotte n'avait et poireaux
je vais réaliser en premier lieu la
farce du haché de veau je vais y
rajouter ma crème liquide
mon persil haché mes échalotes ciselées
mes abats aussi
mes œufs
et après on a l'axe le tout pour faire
notre farce
donc on utilise du veau parce que c'est
le violet et il faut savoir que la poule
de Houdan elle est finie aussi au lait
donc l'association des deux produits se
marient très bien
[Musique]
on va la remettre et après il faut pas
hésiter à la laisser reposer au moins
une heure vraiment pour tous les
aromates
prennent bien le goût au niveau du veau
maintenant on va s'attaquer à la
garniture de notre poule au pot
donc moi j'aime bien laisser des gros
morceaux donc c'est les légumes qui vont
nous servir à parfumer le bouillon
qui vont prendre toutes les saveurs de
la volaille donner leur saveur à la
volaille
[Musique]
donc là il s'est passé une heure de
temps et maintenant on va tout
simplement
remplir notre poule dedans
et après je vais venir tout simplement
la brider pour éviter que la face
ressort pendant le pochage
le but c'est pas de faire de la haute
couture le but c'est vraiment de faire
en sorte que ce soit
ce soit fermé
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant on a plus qu'à mettre tout
dans un bouillon avec les légumes les
aromates le sel le poivre notre vin
blanc et notre poule dedans et on attend
maintenant au moins 8 heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]